as a species we have come incredibly far
in our journey towards knowledge and
understanding we know how to propel
rocket ships into space and land them on
other planets we know how to measure
something as minut as an atom we know
how to open up a human body repair its
heart and then close the body back up
nearly as good as new however there is
still so much missing so much still on
the table after two hundred thousand
years of modern human existence
we remain eluded by some of the most
important and fundamental things that
affect us things that might make one
wonder how we've lived this long without
this information question one why do we
sleep common theories about why we sleep
suggest things like conserving energy
and restoring parts of the body similar
to how we might reset a computer however
when asleep we only burn around 100
fewer calories compared to when we are
awake and most of the same biological
restorations that we do while asleep
also happen while we're awake so it's
inconclusive
- what degrees sleep is actually
necessary for these functions there are
a variety of other theories for why we
sleep but ultimately all we know for
certain is that we need sleep we don't
actually know why this essentially means
that we all spend one third of our lives
doing something without any clear reason
for doing it we just don't have a choice
- why do we dream dreams could very well
mean something important about who we
are and who we become they could be a
result of our brain organizing memories
and strengthening skills and
understandings they could be a way for
us to prepare for negative situations or
an attempt to fulfill desires or
rheems could mean nothing and have no
purpose or meaningful cause whatsoever
we simply don't know we just live in
spite of this important information and
then continue to have around four dreams
per night hoping that they aren't
negatively messing with our life too
much three what is consciousness the
human brain is regarded as the most
complicated object in the known universe
it's accepted that the brain is what
provides consciousness which provides
you with your sense of you and your
ability to discern the world we
understand a lot about the different
parts of the brain and what it means to
be conscious however the source of all
consciousness itself and what
consciousness fundamentally is or isn't
remains entirely unclear the very entity
of consciousness which allowed you to
click on this video and want to learn
about what you don't know can't figure
out why it itself even exists in the
first place or how it's forming an
internal experience out of this moment
this issue is described by the hard
problem of consciousness which is our
inability to understand the relationship
between physical phenomena and our
personal experience of it this means
that we all identify with our
consciousness without knowing what we
are actually identifying with for do we
have free will there are lots of
theories concerning whether or not we
have freedom of choice or if our lives
are predetermined by the sequences of
cause-and-effect patterns in the case
where we do not have free will described
by the concept of determinism even
though it feels like we are making
choices for ourselves the string of
events preceding our actions or what
actually caused us to do what we do not
our willfulness alternatively
in the case where we do have free
we'll we are not constrained by the
conditions of the past everything in the
future is uncertain and random and we
possess the ability to influence it with
our volition no one knows for sure
what's true when it comes to free will
or to what extent it may be some
paradoxical combination of both free
will and determinism or perhaps
something completely different
five is anything objectively real we
primarily sense the world through our
eyes ears nose tongue and skin all of
these sense organs transmit information
from the physical world into our brains
we then analyzed the information and
form conclusions however every piece of
information is received by sense organs
that no one else can have in the exact
same form in the exact same place at the
exact same time on one's evaluation of
the sensory information is entirely
based on their unique prior
understanding of the world no one can
ever be in your head and truly see the
world from your perspective just like
you can never be in anyone else's and so
one's experience of reality is and will
always be subjected not only that but
our sensory perception is constantly
being tricked by the outside world
making us experience things that aren't
always there or miss things that are all
of this raises the following in order
for something to be observed like the
universe it needs an observer but an
observer requires a means of observation
like sensory organs and a conscious
brain to make discernments but how can
something observe while not being
limited to the conditions of its means
of observation it can't this raises at
least two possible answers to the
questioning if anything is objective
real either there is an objective truth
to the nature of everything which is
indifferent to observation but current
humanity can simply not access it or
nothing is objectively real and what
appears real is relative to the nature
and abilities of the observing party all
we have is our own brain and we can
never experience the world from outside
it according to the concept of the
egocentric predicament this means
everything outside of one's brain is
impossible to ever prove as real or not
all we can do is hope that at least
something is it's clear that no matter
how far we have come or how smart and
powerful we may feel we're still
embryonic in the birth of knowledge and
understanding there is mystery every
time we go to bed and every time we wake
up every time we perceive something
every time we make a decision every time
we think about the world or the universe
or ourself the fact that we are aware
enough to ask questions and self-honest
enough to admit when we don't know the
answers is a testament to the beauty of
being human perhaps being a human is to
reside somewhere in the space between
knowing and unknowing a space that
allows us to speculate consider learn
and create stories art and videos like
these to have something incredible to
talk about with lovers friends and
family arguably to be human is the most
fascinating experience in the history of
the universe not because we have all the
answers but because we will always have
enough to ask about the ones we don't
or maybe we'll find all the answers one
day and then life will be even better
who knows
thank you for watching if he found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder